this is a fish called a Bashir Basheer's
are found in Africa and like all fish
they live in water that is until they
met researcher Emily standin who was
working at McGill University in Canada
stand and thought that she would try
raising bashir on land why you asked to
see if it helps them walk it isn't quite
as mad as it sounds let's go back a step
Bashir's unusually among fish actually
have lungs as well as skills so they can
breathe air but having lungs doesn't
mean you can walk as demonstrated by
this lung fish's failed attempts at
perambulation but there are fish that do
take tentative steps onto land arguably
the masters of fishy walking are these
mudskippers Basheer's - can make flappy
forays over land but they walk in a very
different way in fact scientists think
they walk like the ancestors of all
tetrapods might have walked fishapods if
you will studying how they react to a
terrestrial environment could help us
understand how the very first fishy
footsteps were taken on land
stand-ins the shears grew up in a
decidedly damp but totally terrestrial
environment
she and her team set up some high-speed
cameras placed the four shears on a
stage and let them go they compared
their walking abilities with those of
the shears raised more traditionally you
know in water and they saw some
differences subtle but distinct the
landlubbers lifted their heads higher
planted their fins more efficiently and
slipped less often than their aquatic
associates
this suggests that Basheer's have the
ability to modify their behavior in
response to their environment a concept
called plasticity this is the first time
that plasticity has been shown to be a
potential facilitator of such a major
evolutionary step as our ancestors
crawling out of the Seas and onto land
but it doesn't stop there when standing
examined the skeletons of her
land-living Bashir's she found that
their muscles and bones had changed as
they adapted to walking it appears that
the Basheer's anatomy is as plastic as
their behavior these changes looked
strikingly similar to the kinds of
changes scientists see in the fossil
record as ancient species started making
the transition to land it might not look
elegant but don't be deceived after all
one small flappy step of our fishy
ancestors may have led to the giant
leaps of mankind